there we go
welcome to your weekly ticket
gal gadot has been cast as cleopatra in
a new movie about the queen of egypt
patty jenkins the director behind wonder
woman will lead the epic historical
drama for paramount pictures
according to variety the studio
reportedly defeated
apple universal warner brothers and
netflix in the auction to win production
rights
gadot confirmed the news on twitter
writing i love embarking on new journeys
i love the excitement of new projects
the thrill of bringing new stories to
life
cleopatra is a story i wanted to tell
for a very long time
can't be more grateful about this a-team
here's some halloween month news
there's a new resident evil adaptation
happening
johannes roberts said that the reboot
will be an origin story adaptation with
ties to capcom's classic survival horror
games
the story will be set in 1998 in raccoon
city
casting for the film includes caia
scadillario of maze runner fame and
ant-man's hannah john common
who will play claire redfield and jill
valentine respectively
robbie mel tom hopper evan jogia and
neil mcdonough will
also star and benedict cumberbatch will
star in spider-man 3 as doctor strange
in what is said to be a mentor role for
tom holland's spider-man
similar mentorship like roles were
previously held by robert downey jr
and samuel l jackson doctor strange and
spider-man previously interacted with
one another in avengers infinity war
cumberbatch is also slated to appear in
a second doctor strange movie titled
multiverse of madness
directed by sam raimi both films are
supposed to begin filming
this year there's a reason why films
like poltergeist your next and panic
room rank highly among movie fans
it brings one of their worst fears to
life being trapped inside a house with
an attacker or entity
the thrills of home invasion and haunted
house movies offer some of the most
intense horror
and some of the biggest surprises so
this week we're taking a look at
fandango now's list of the most
terrifying horror in the house films
and today i'm joined by film critic and
host of the unspooled podcast amy
nicholson
who's gonna help us break down this list
of [ __ ] in this house
uh hey amy how's it going it's not bad
it's a little spooky how are you
it is that's your house huh
oh yeah i mean do you think i should put
some lights on
you know what i think it's good for now
i'll just keep an eye on what's going on
behind you
so amy what is your favorite film from
this list
okay i had to pick two because this is a
really really really good list
i thought that i would knock on your
door with two picks from deep in the
whole basement you know
the first one that i want to talk to you
about it stars one of the most famous
legends in hollywood who adds
class to a home invasion flick it's wait
until dark have you seen this movie
no oh let me tell you about it oh wait
until dark stars
the great audrey hepburn you know you
know her for being like the romantic
harrowing and
breakfast at tiffany's and sabrina
audrey hepburn already had
four oscar nominations and one win when
she agreed to be and wait until dark
playing a blind woman whose house is
invaded by three
murderers now the murderers are trying
to get into her house because they want
to steal back some heroin that's hidden
in a doll that she doesn't even know
that is there
but really what's going on is that this
is a horror film that is so
physical and mental like it gets into
the psychology
of being in a of the pair in the
paranoia of being a woman who's like
walking in her house right by a murderer
that she doesn't even know is there
because she's blind and she can't see
him but she can sense that something is
wrong
i mean audrey hepburn is no like vin
diesel or liam neeson so she is
definitely outmatched in this and if
you're wondering like how does she
defend herself how does she fight
herself back i mean the title is a hint
but
watching her fight back is really
gripping
i mean so much that wait until dark it
didn't even just like
hurt the oscar winners like classy
reputation it actually got her her fifth
oscar nomination okay yeah i want to see
that i want to see audrey hepburn do
some action
i think that's i think that's overdue in
my life
yeah audrey horror oscar winning action
what else do you need
yeah i do well for my second pick i was
thinking
what is scarier than your house getting
invaded by three killers
the only answer is how about 10 000
killers oh that's yeah that's worse
that's definitely worse
i mean i was talking about arachnophobia
the 1990 horror comedy
now that one i have to admit
it even though it's a horror comedy i
find it really hard to laugh at because
i am so freaked out by spiders just
especially ones that can bite you once
and then you shrivel into a mummy and
you die
i mean if you haven't seen it all you
really didn't know is that the killer
venezuelan spiders in this film are
nasty
and everybody's favorite swag rain gas
back john goodman is in this film he's
amazing he plays like a blowhard
exterminator who does not take these
spiders seriously enough
but i think what makes this movie so
effective you know
way more even than like an exorcism
movie where people do dumb stuff that
makes stuff worse
is that spiders are real and literally
everything that people
do in this movie that puts them in
danger is stuff that you might do today
a person dies turning on a lamp so i
have to admit like i'm kind of surprised
kale that arachnophobia was marketed to
kids because this movie personally
ruined my life
i actually am still haunted by the one
where the spider is in the shower he's
on the he comes down from the shower
head
just while someone's just doing the
thing they do every day
but that makes me wonder does it change
the experience
when you watch it at home like a home
invasion or a haunted house movie
to you it does but you have to be strict
with yourself i think as a viewer
like if you want to get the full haunted
house horror film experience at home
you have to turn off all the lights and
you have to put your phone down if
you're distracted at all for a minute
it'll take you out like
i think a home haunted house horror film
that's really hard to say
it demands from you complete respect to
the art of getting
scared out of your mind i still would
rather not do that alone that made that
like amplifies it a hundred percent
what about just like a haunted house
movie like what do you think is like a
good
haunted house movie from this list well
the one that really popped out to me
is what lies beneath the film from i
think it's 2000 by robert zemeckis
we don't really think of like robert
zemeckis as a man of horror
but this film i really love it you know
it's
kind of a hitchcockian ghost story
starring
michelle pfeiffer and harrison ford when
they are both just so
beautiful and what what lia's video is
about
is that you know they're this perfect
couple and then michelle pfeiffer starts
to realize
that there's a spirit in her house
trying to tell her something and she's
trying to tell her something bad about
her husband
so it's got that whole element not just
of ghosts knocking over pictures of
people thinking you're going a little
bit crazy
but of not being able to trust your
loved one it ends
i don't know if it's a spoiler to say
that the ghost is real this is just i
think a really perfect tiny little film
and if you want a fun fact about the
making of
it robert zemeckis made this film during
the making of castaway you know it took
him forever to make castaway because tom
hanks had to change weight so much
so in one of the periods when tom hanks
was i think gaining weight
and he was like i'm just going to go
make this little film and it is a great
little film so
what lies believe beneath highly
recommend it's like you you go get fat
i'm gonna make this scary movie
and i do want to make a correction
robert zemeckis i do think of him
uh with horror because he made one of
the scariest scenes in cinema
where uh they dip that shoe in the dip
and who framed roger rabbit and it
haunts me to this day right
that robert zemeckis is i agree with you
on robert zemeckis
but anyway amy nicholson thank you so
much where can people find you
everywhere um unspooled is launching its
second season right now where we are
building you know in our first season we
uh
went through the whole afi 100 list and
now we're building our own
we're actually doing a little horror
series right now everything from the
original 1931 frankenstein up to the
babadook so you should join
us awesome well thank you so much amy
thank you bye
available to watch at home on friday
love and monsters
don't move let me see it don't move amy
is here
okay ready
i love it that's super sweet because
it's terrible
[Music]
oh my god love in monsters is set in a
post-apocalyptic time when giant
monsters have taken over earth's surface
forcing mankind into underground
colonies one young man decides to risk
it all to find his high school
sweetheart
and along his dangerous journey he makes
unlikely friends including a heroic dog
and a pair of survivalists
who help him survive the
monster-infested road to true love
also available to watch at home on
friday the devil has a name
the net present value rule states if you
make more money doing it
than what it would cost if you get
caught doing it continue doing it
widowed broke and adrift
farmer fred stern finds a new purpose in
life when he learns that a psychotic
matriarch of an
oil company is polluting his water but
as his crusade against the powers that
be
spill out of the courtroom and into his
personal life fred must find a way to
avoid the ruin of his farm
his family and his dream inspired by
bizarre
true events the devil has a name
comedically pulls back the curtain on
the culture of greed
that poisoned corporate america from sea
to polluted sea
the film stars david stratharin kate
bosworth haley joel
osmond martin sheen and edward james
almost all right that's it for today but
check out that full list of horror in
the house films in the link below and
leave a comment and let us know which
one's your favorite i'm kale and i'll
see you next time